Un magnifique mâle shiba inu, de retour au studio après une longue période d'absence
il profitera régulièrement de la moquette pour se mettre sur le dos et réclamer des petits câlins et des bisous pendant de nombreuses minutes
*Bruit de gaga*
Mais il sent très mauvais de l'haleine.
Les Amis ! Qu'est ce qu'il y a de plus drôle que la chaîne de squeezie ? Tout !
Mais qu'est ce qu'il y a de plus drôle que des fails de
panoramas ? Et oui ! Cette fameuse option disponible en 2018 sur tous les téléphones du monde.
Elle fait des ravages mec, elle ouvre des portes qui
mènent aux enfers !
Pour ceux qui savent pas ou qui pratiquent très peu le panorama, c'est vrai que généralement on utilise ça pour faire une
photo d'un paysage, mais c'est très déconseillé de faire un panorama quand tu prends une photo de quelqu'un qui pose devant quelque chose
Pourquoi ? Parce que si la personne bouge,
l'algorithme va vraiment créer un p*tain de monstre ! On va checker ensemble ce que ça peut créer vous allez voir c'est un
DELIRE ! Pourquoi je parle comme un présentateur télé ? Je ne sais pas ! *En anglais* The mountain giant (le géant de la montagne)
Comment c'est possible mec ? Non ça n'a pas du tout fait ça, on dirait un montage sony vegas pro regarde, il est mal détouré
carrément !  Ah si  ok, il était en gros plan ok si, il était juste vraiment en très gros plan devant la caméra, et ça a...Ok c'est bon
C'est attack on Titan in real life (l'attaque des titans dans la vraie vie).
Ah voilà, ça c'est le cas classique
d’échec de panorama. The classic one on l'appelle. Ça te fait une traînée dégueulasse derrière la tête là,  en plus à lui a déformé
l'oeil et tout ou alors, c'est son vrai visage...
*Musique creepy*
*Tuez-moi* Horrible ! This man on google earth (cet homme sur google earth)
Ah bah oui, puisque comme ils balayent google earth, c'est pareil, ça peut créer des problèmes de...*rire*
Oh, mec c'est fou ! Ça a relié le haut de ce mec au bas de quelqu'un d'autre. C'est très creepy, j'adore.
Ah oui !
L'échec des panorama, souvent ça rallonge ou ça
raccourci quelqu'un ou un objet. Et là par exemple ça a raccourci un bus et ça a créé le premier
p*tain de bus deux roues ! C'est vraiment un minibus mec !
C'est incroyable ! Mec, tu veux le faire en photoshop tu y arrives pas
Si ça ce trouve, y a un monde dans lequel tout n'est que euh...
fail de panorama. Genre quand tu prends le bus, c'est que celui là qui vient.
Notez ce délire de 0 à 10 on est là. On est là yes.
Ah ok lui son téléphone il a une feature pour faire un selfie grand-angle et en fait ça utilise la même technologie que le panorama.
whah mec c'est creepy mon pote ! Nan alors par contre je suis désolé vieux mais ta copine a vraiment fait cette tête.
Le panorama n'a pas pu créer une expression de visage. Ta copine avant de faire cette tête en mode "j'suis belle" a fait cette tête.
Systématiquement. tu l'a juste pris en flagrant délit, le panorama n'a rien fait.
*Rire*
Eh mec, ça crée des choses creepy, mais vraiment !
Regardez ça ! On dirait un enfant qui tient la tête d'un autre enfant qui lui a volé son son jouet. C'est horrible !
J'ai essayé de prendre un panorama de la tour Eiffel et ça a donner un truc génial un truc génial.
OHHH
Mais mec,
c'est archi bien ! Pourquoi
réussir ses panoramas alors que quand tu les foire, ça donne un truc créatif trop cool ! Alors la mec, je suis surpris.
P*tain on a pas les mêmes téléphones
*rire*
C'est vraiment monstrueux mec !
Ah sur les animaux mec c'est drôle ! Comme ils bougent l'animaux (t'as eu combien au bac de français Lucas ?) il va jamais poser, il va bouger
je fais caca dans des raviolis
OHHHHHHH
Oh nan mais mec ! Et en plus j'ai déjà vu cette photo, elle a grave fait le tour cette photo, j'ai déjà vu c'est... ce truc là.
Oui ça c'est du panorama réussi mec ! En plus le fond, tout est parfait quoi, c'est vraiment le truc qui a bougé ! Ah, c'est creepy !
Ça devient une sorte de kangoo chien de m*rde là, désolé, je suis violent mais
Mec ! P*tain mais pourquoi Natsu ça fait pas ça ! Toi tu pourrais être juste un trou du c*l qui marche ?
Bon en vrai t'en est déjà un.
*Note des sous titreur* Natsu : Arête de m'insulter Lucas.
Ah c'est dur ça quand même ! Ah ça, sa pourrait presque démonétiser ma vidéo ! Nan sans déconner !
Ca se trouve mec c'était pas un panorama c'est juste une photo normale et c'est sa vrai tête. Je peux pas m'empêcher de penser ça !
Mais, est-ce que en fait, Stephen Hawking avait pas du tout un handicap mais c'est les gens qui le prenaient en photo qui le prenaient un
panorama et et sa foirait.
*Rire*
Ahhh y a plus de cou.  Vous voyez ceux qui ont des grands cous là, ceux qui complexent là.
Seb. Seb c'est pour toi, voilà.
Je veux pas dire ceux qui, je parle de Seb (on accorde au sous-titreur que c'est une girafe)
l'inverse d'un grand coup ça donne ça mec ! C'est beaucoup moins cool quand même  ! T'es plus proche de tes aisselles en plus.
Donc si tu sues, tu le sens immédiatement plus fort
J'essaie de remonter le moral à un pote en pleine vidéo. VOILA  BON! Alors... Oulà.
*musique creepy*
Non, non mec ! Ils avaient raison depuis le début ! *Dans une ancienne vidéo* Earth is plate (la Terre est plate)
Vous avez sûrement entendu parler de ça il ya une communauté de gens
qui est convaincue que la Terre est plate
Le mec il était à l'extrémité de la planète là ! Et il a vu la cascade qui est au bord de la planète là, parce qu'en fait elle est plate !  P*tain !
P*tain mais c'est
DINGUE comme c'est bien fait ! Je te jure tu veux le photoshoper (du verbe photochoper 😉) tu y arrive pas ça . C'est dingue ça créer vraiment des trucs
crédible. C'est ça qui fait flipper en fait je trouve. C'est que ça crée des trucs
crédible.Tu passais le week end à Londres en couple tranquille et tout, t'as juste pris un panneau, tu vois le bus qui a cette gueule sur
ta photo, tu bloques, tu remet tout en question
*rire* Ah sur un bébé c'est horrible, c'est terrifiant !
J'avais déjà pas trop envie de faire des enfants mais alors la mec
le mec est devenu
Wiilston d'overwatch. Oh c'est terrifiant ! (Tu vas répéter ça combien de temps Lucas ?)
On dirait un Slunderman mais qui a un peu trop mangé. C'est fou !
Le retour du chien 2 pattes. Mais, mec
en fait les dinosaures c'est pareil ! Mec le t-rex c'est un panorama qui a foiré.
Nan mais soyons d'accord c'est vraiment ça
Si y'a des t-rex qui regardent la vidéo, je suis désolé mais à un moment il faut l'admettre.
*Rire*
Ces photos de dieu
improvisées mec. C'est incroyable.  J'aimerais trop d'avoir une de moi, je suis jaloux. Personne ne parle dans le dos de ce mec
*Rire*
La légende est parfaite mec
c'est si vrai. Personne ne surveille mieux ses arrières que lui. Ça n'existe pas.
Les amis les panoramas fail c'est terminé, ils arrivent à leur limite
Y en a, il y en a plus en fait, tout simplement
Oh !
C'est un thread bonus ! Ça y est maintenant y'a des thread bonus qui tombent !
Connaissez-vous la paréidolie ? Mec je bégaye sur des mots pétés et le mot paréidolie il passe nickel quoi ! Alors que "boulanger" j'ai du
mal à le dire à côté c'est incroyable. Notre cerveau à nous les humains il aime pas l'inconnu. Il structure en permanence son environnement et
il veut donner du sens là où y'en a pas forcément. Et la paréidolie c'est ce phénomène où en fait on va associer à un
stimulus
flou et inconnu à quelque chose de clair et identifiable
Sauf que contrairement aux illusions d'optique qui marchent de la même manière pour tout le monde, la paréidolie ton vécu, ton expérience, ta culture etc
va influencer ce que tu vois. *voix google home :  test de rorschach*
Ça y est je suis grillé et humilié. J'étais sur haut parleur
J'allais dire que c'est sûr ça qu'est basé le fameux test de
*voix de google home* : Rorschach
Elle le dit très bien ! Bref, on a très souvent
tendance à voir des visages là où il n'y a pas forcément de visage, on a tendance à repérer des yeux et une bouche alors
que ça n'a rien à voir ce qu'on voit. Et apparemment ça viendrait de notre capacité à identifier très facilement un
visage donc une présence en fait. C'est un instinct qu'on a et je trouve ça hyper intéressant. Commençons avec...
Oh oh ça fait flipper mec
Avec cette photo d'un feu dont la fumée
semble afficher
un visage. Le nez ici, la bouche ici, les yeux ici. Voilà vous voyez ce genre d'exemple. Alors qu'en fait c'est carrément juste de
la fumée y'a pas de
visages ou de présence dans cette fumée. Cet arbre dans pokémon, qui ressemble à un mec musclé énervé qui contracte. C'est de la paréidolie voilà.
Cette boîte a connu des jours meilleurs
J'adoreeeee comment notre cerveau nous joue des tours c'est fou ! On a presque de la peine pour cette boite p*tain !
*Bruit de surprise* Faut pas que je montre ça à Natsu mec
C'est quoi c'est des pains au chocolat ! On dirai clairement qu'il y a un shiba enfermé dedans mec ! Attends j'aimerais lui montrer non il va... Dès que je
montre une vidéo de chiens, il comprend pas qu'il y a un chien. Je suis débile faut que j'arrête d'être gaga. (ah ça oui)
Non mais y en a des
IN-CROY-ABLES. Le mec se met de la crème hydratante sur les mains, ça crée un petit chat mignon. On n'a pas la même manière de
se mettre de la crème très clairement. Quand ton ventre est content de voir une bière.
*Rire*
C'est incroyable ! Son ventre est heureux !
La situation est folle. C'est drôle.
Oh là là, le bouchon d'un réservoir d'essence qui fait l'ombre de Batman. C'est tellement emblématique Batman que dès qu'on voit deux petits trucs comme
ça hop, c'est batman ! Stephen Hawking
*rire*
Arrêtez de faire des refs à Stephen Hawking, après on va croire je me moque des handicapés et ma chaîne youtube va
fermer, tout simplement. Mais ce qui est triste c'est que c'est vrai
ça me fait penser à Stephen Hawking, parce que le truc que j'ai vu le plus penché, finalement, c'était la tête de Stephen Hawking à
cause de son handicap. Donc c'est vrai que du coup quand je vois un truc qui est penché de la même manière, ça me fait penser
à lui. C'est fou
J'ai mis longtemps à le voir. On dirait une grand-mère qui met du rouge à lèvres
*rire*
Mais mec, comment on réussit à voir aussi t'sais
précisément un truc quoi ! Et c'est vrai que les gros yeux ça fait penser aux grosses lunettes de grand mère, le petit bras qui met du rouge
à lèvres sur la bouche en "O" la p*tain mais mec !
*Rire*
Même la nature s'y met gros !
C'est normal ça ? On va arrêter les bêtises.
Ah la fameuse multiprise c'est vrai  ! C'est
l'exemple de la palé...rolie...doli...
Bas ça y est, voilà, il fallait bien que je me foire à un moment. Je pense que la première fois ou, même si tu sais pas encore
ce que c'est, t'es victime de paréidolie,  c'est en regardant une prise. C'est le truc Number One (numéro 1). Deux trous un plus gros trou
Le tout sans parler de sexe évidemment. Booberries (contraction de blueberrie : mirtille et boobs)
C'est vrai on dirai clairement
des s*ins. A tel point que peut-être que le robot va détecté
que c'est des s*ins et que la vidéo va être démonétisé c'est possible. Clément on le laisse au montage juste pour voir. Je veux que la vidéo soit
démonétisée, que je revendique et qu'un mec aille à ce moment-là il fasse bon effectivement c'est pas des s*ins c'est des raisins ok.
OHHH
Alors là, là c'est bien joué. En forme de guitare, par dessus des lignes électriques, donc on dirait que les lignes sont les cordes de
la guitare c'est magnifique
*Rire* Oh les pauvres...
Ils savent. Ils savent qu'ils sont trop vieux, qu'il y a des interrupteurs bien mieux qu'eux maintenant qui sont fabriqués.
Des interrupteurs plus beaux, plus ergonomiques, ils
le savent ils vont dégager
*exclamation de surprise*
Wah j'ai mis du temps à le voir mec, mais là c'est
creepy as f*ck. Vous voyez ou pas ? *avec un accent quebecois nul à ch**r* Vous voyez ou pas là ?
Ah, celui là il est trop connu mec. En même temps je lai vu sur Twitter
le truc des deux avions qui tapent une barre. C'est pareil, c'est la paréidolie. Vous voyez vous étiez victime de ça sans même savoir
ce que c'était comme phénomène. N'êtes vous pas content à l'issue de cette vidéo de savoir mettre un mot sur votre ressenti ?
Ouais j'essaie de trouver une utilité à regarder mes vidéos mais non.
Ouahhhh
Regarde mec,
Incroyable ça ! Ils envoient de l'eau sur un éléphant et en envoyant de l'eau ça forme une tête d'éléphant c'est
incroyable ! Ah mec j'adore !
Ah mec, c'est creepy ! Je suis sur qu'il y a très longtemps,
on savait pas mettre un mot sur ce phénomène par exemple et du coup on croyait vraiment que l'arbre qui avait une forme
du visage, c'était quelqu'un qui était réincarné en arbre. S'suis sur
Maintenant que la science a grandement évoluée, on peut mettre un mot sur des phénomènes et mieux les comprendre. c'est intéressant je trouve voilà j'étais le
Voilà, c'était le petit moment premier degré de la vidéo. Et bien les amis,
c'est la fin de cette vidéo, j'espère qu'elle vous a plu sur les thread red-it, dans ce cas n’hésitez pas à l'aimer, comme d'habitude Ben voilà, 2 thread en 1,
c'est cadeau, ça régale, dont l'un des deux qui est
quand même basé sur un
phénomène du cerveau qui est quand même incroyable quoi ! C'est fou, je deviens parano mec, je regarde tout autour de moi dans l'espoir de voir
des visages. J'ai envie, je devient accro à ça, c'est fou. Sur twitter, hésitez pas à m'envoyer si vous foirez votre panorama ou si vous voyez un
truc qui vous fait penser à un visage, envoyez le moi sur twitter, voilà ça m'interresse : @xsqueezie
Je sais que quand je dis ça, après je reçois des tweets en rapport et ça me fait kiffer voilà.
Je vous dis à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo, portez vous bien, je finis la vidéo comme je l'ai commencé en faisant des câlins à
mon chien
Je t'aime Natsu mais tu t'en fous, il y a que le mot "croquette" qui t'intéresse *Note des sous-titreurs* Natsu: non c'est le mot FERME TA P*TAIN DE G***LE SQUEEZIE!!!!!